a lot of false promises we've gotten a
lot of false promises from
conservative judges from concert quote
unquote conservative politicians
actually ufc fighter jorge maz vidalin i
don't know how to pronounce his name
i've never heard of him i've never even
watched ufc
but this guy i like him okay because
this guy
he clearly sees a political situation
very well
and he just came out very strongly and
endorsed trump
because he doesn't want to be suckered
anymore by false promises
i'm gonna let you in on something the
democrats just think that they're
entitled to the latino vote
they think that we just have to hand it
over to them that's right
we sure as hell don't
they got to show us what they could do
for us what they could do for our
communities
we're not going to buy the same wolf
tickets and false promises
that destroyed great countries like
venezuela and cuba it's not going to
happen
you know what else is not going to work
for them playing despacito on your cell
phone
it's a panda to us hell no
you got to give us some credit for
having heads on our shoulders
i'm going to wrap this up some words of
barack obama
he said elections have consequences that
is true
and those words have never been more
true than they are today
we either reelect president trump and
keep america great
amen
or we let joe biden destroy the greatest
country the world has ever seen
very strong endorsement his delivery is
terrific
it's just look this is obviously like a
pretty macho normal guy
you know it's not very woke i would
suspect in in his comportment
he goes it's like yeah man look they've
been lying to us they pander to us
they think we're a bunch of idiots they
take us for granted on the basis of our
race
usually and we're just not going to take
that anymore and it's very matter of
fact and i that
i like the matter-of-fact approach to
trump because the left becomes very
hysterical like those gals that we were
playing on the show yesterday
but the right very matter of fact yeah
okay maybe you don't like this about
trump or that about trump but he's doing
a good job actually the reasoning
that jorge gives for why you should
support trump
beyond you know how offensive it is that
biden and the dems pander to people and
lie to people and have empty promises
he gives a great sports analogy that i
think is good reasoning we should all
keep in mind
i'm a professional athlete and i've been
one for most of my life so i've always
seen things through a sports lens
that makes donald trump our head coach
and before the global pandemic
we were winning super bowls and when
you're winning super bowls you don't
fire the coach
you don't doesn't matter if you don't
like the plays he runs the players he
puts on the field
are what he says on twitter you sure as
hell don't replace him for another coach
that's been in the business for 47 years
at every level
and never won a game
[Applause]
this is a great analogy and it gets to a
big difference between the left and the
right because
notice he didn't say here look trump's
our quarterback
look trump trump is like tom brady okay
and he's a winner and he's a winner
because that would suggest
that trump is doing all of these things
himself but we know trump isn't doing
all of these things himself
we know that the president actually has
relatively little direct power
much of his power is from the bully
pulpit much of his power is putting some
people in place
that then carry out these operations but
the president himself it's not like he's
sitting on his computer all day like
typing away emails and and you know uh
filing like spreadsheets and things like
that he's not doing that
his job is one of inspiration to the
people
and then of appointment to get good
people in place that can actually run
this massive government
he's not the quarterback he's the head
coach he's that and we're the players
and he's done a good job getting us all
to like
play very well and his appointees are
the players
and the pete and he's he's done a good
job there and this this
analogy of the to the head coach doesn't
reflect very well on joe biden
because joe biden's been in the game for
47 years and he hasn't
won a single game i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you